I grew up watching you on SNL I am
overjoyed like the entire world that
you're gonna be going back in December
yeah and the Christmas show I'm so
excited
with SNL because you've not been back to
perform in since you left are you
already thinking about like some of the
things that you want to do or is it sort
of so far away I'll think about it in
November yeah you know that show really
you know it's it's the show starts on
Monday and then on Saturday night it's
over at one o'clock in the morning and
then the week you have one day off then
the Week starts again with a brand new
show a brand new so you can't really
even go okay what am i what will I do
what sketches I study because it doesn't
start till you get there at Monday you
got to get there and meet those writers
and meet everybody and then talk about
you know what are you thinking about
right so to you can't be months away
from you kidding there's no way to
prepare for that months out my last
thing for you and I got to go um I I
heard you might be doing Beverly Hills
Cop for yeah that's what we're doing
after coming to America we're doing a
Beverly Hills Cop and then then the plan
is to get back on stage and do stand-up
and then kind of like that's what I'll
be doing mostly is stand up and move
Beverly Hills Cop I'd be like that kind
of like that's like I keep saying it
this is more these movies and and
Saturday Night Live it's kind of like
I'm looking at it as a book in and if I
decided I just want to stay on the couch
forever I ended it on a funny note and
I'll do stand-up if I'm feeling creative
I can get on the stage and do my
stand-up and if you know some incredible
filmmaker comes along with some great
movie
there's some great opportunity but I'm
not gonna be making movies you know two
or three a year like I did back in the
early days now because I like to just be
home with the kids
I've heard thank you so much yeah we're
fantastic in this I wish you nothing but
the best off thanks